Vào mừng vùng sĩ nhiều hơn, phải tập định thêm ngoài dờ.
Vậy phải có hợp nhau đó là dân biến đoạn.
Có con biệt ký, bất đề mà sẽ chung thương biệt không thể chung tỏi.
Tất cả, hợp định nhau nhiều hợp thì cái tình hình, cái khi thấy không thể đi lên nó là nhiều.
Từ mi Nam ra, hoa mình mắt khi đó đi tòi tốt cho nó mọi hôm nay ở hợi lớm.
Nắng là xúc hỏa có gì xố.
Ờ, kì mà chúng tôi vẫn khăn ngày hợp lì không người dưới.
Bỏ của chuyện này nó đòi rất nhiều yêu cầu
Về thân pháp của tân pháp tự nhiệm pháp
Bệ cước pháp đòi hoàn, những cái đậu tăng này mạnh mẽ
Và đối với đặc tôn gì nó là cái đòi đặc biệt hà hồn
Nói phải lánh phải sát đòn
Sao tự tế trên đau cảo đu quín như phải có một cái tình tình tình
Và có một cái chi quý tầm cảm nhất biết được hiện là các loại dùng theo đúng kịch bản chừng kì
Mà bán hư đẹp và bán thật kích đá đưa ra
Sặc biệt phải chứ giọc nó phải cao
Để từ đó sắc lịch được nhất của mình
Tương đọc đá của mình tương loại trong hồ mình cho tốt